oh
irène chagnaud propose en compagnie de
gilbert le voyage sans passeport
et gilbert le que vous nous aviez promis
la semaine dernière une passionnante
pêche aux gros poissons jointe me disent
oh oui nous arrivons justement dans un
seau on les trouve sur les indiens qui
les pêchent ils ne pêchent pas comme ici
à l'accueil d'une canne à pêche
ils pêchent à l'arc ces poissons remonte
le courant un petit peu comme on fait la
truite et on les trouve dans ces remous
ils sont énormes comme vous verrez tout
à l'heure en l'indien est obligé de
barre des moyens chromatique parfois se
placer juste dans le sang alors il
observe le poisson il attend que celui
ci comme c'est un poisson assez plat se
présente bien deux flancs pour que sa
flèche est beaucoup plus de chances de
toucher au but
une fois que le poisson est pris il est
faux ils arrivent qui est entraînée par
le courant
là ce n'était pas le cas il s'est trouvé
accroché par une roche il lui décoche
une autre flèche veiller sur qu'il
n'avait chaque pas dans quand le poisson
entraîné par le courant et les autres
indiens en bacs le canot qui leur grand
père
c'était joli poisson jusqu'à 7 ou 8 kg
et plus je n'y serai pas de balance je
peux pas me rende compte voit saint
palais on appelle ça un coup mal lu
c'est bon c'est bon mais s'est plaint
d'arette j'ai pu en faire l'expérience
acquise à james avec le couac lors la
pêche terminé le augmenteront au village
toujours votre mille manières sur notre
bannière qui rentre de sa chasse aux
papillons et le manque pas d'emmener son
fils à chaque fois dans la récompense la
première des récompenses sont les
cigarettes ils les ont après jamais
avant maintenant mais avant parce que ça
leur donne avant et il faut leur donner
encore après ça ils sont très exigeants
ils sont at mendiants même nous sommes
rescap
non vous disiez nous sommes restés à peu
près de deux jours chez des alliances
pour ses prises de vue et à la au début
on même pour au point de vue photo je
pouvais faire des clichés monde
absolument rien quand on est reparti
était 100 francs 150 francs pour faire
un cliché vous allez les années il
fallait les données il n'acceptait pas
l'envoyer si on était resté huit jours
c'était peut-être 500 clichés
oui il n'y a pas de mesure but mais
qu'est ce qu'il fout l'argent leur
argent il leur arrive de descendre à
saint laurent
oui le faire l'expédition sens qu'on
presque manière fait ils descendent à la
ville elle s achète un tas de petits
colis fiche écoles offrent d'ailleurs à
prix d'or
j'ai des distances fils de cuisine
vraiment et on fume très jeune ah oui et
puis voyez comme un pompier contribuerez
sûreté il résistera pas oui et c'est
tenir avec un chic dans le village des
indiens est assez réduit
celui ci était encore assez grand il
conforte plusieurs cars b sont descendus
sorte de cases il ya un simple toit
briller la can le quart beda clerbois
simplement à la wii console wii où ils
étendent leurs hamacs ne soit un autre
bannière entendant le soir se promène
avec un jeune indien pour voir un petit
peu la vie du pays lors cette boule que
cet indien offre à demain l'accès est
enduite à l'enduit par le produit la
teinture de roucou 10e trou dans le
litre par terre c'est du bas latin
alors quand cette poule e balade placera
bien imprégné de roucou certain que
rouge elle le passe soyez-en geste très
agréable d'ailleurs pour l'accord de son
mari
ils s'en mettent partout même des fois
sur les chevaux
et ce à une odeur spécial non alors
point de vue usage soit dix ans au
progrès éloigner les moustiques et c'est
le protéger je ne pense pas j'ai
l'impression plutôt qu'une ancienne
coutume dans certains indiens ne veulent
plus conforme et parce que paula les
danses du soir qui auront lieu tout à
l'heure j'avais demandé à tous les
indiens de se teindre en rousse coup et
certains m'ont dit non non pas moi moi
par ou alors je suppose qu'il y en a qui
ne veut plus accepter ce qu'ils feraient
que ce serait plutôt une coutume parce
que des moustiques unis en sommes sauvés
comme partout ici nous assistons la
fabrication d'un calame b on appellerait
ça en france un cache sexe
celui-ci effet de nombreuses petites
perles qui sont enfilées sur des fils de
coton de la récolte c'est entre terry
ils ont énormément de patience ils sont
nonchalants alors en principe
nonchalance déjà vous donne pas mal de
patience un avantage sur les nerveux et
celle qui perd on pourrait se demander
d'où elles viennent bien une chose très
curieuse elles viennent soit disant de
paris en ce sit in win il avait su avant
de partir par un père qu'il y avait un
fabricant à paris chez qui on pouvait
trouver
je me suis renseigné j'ai cherché
partout mais pas pu trouver et vous
allez me rapporte non j'en ai acheté
quelques unes à saint laurent
quand je suppose que les commerçants de
saint laurent les achètent peu à part
ils connaissent la combine
ouais et ses perles sont achetés à saint
laurent quand tu le descendeur faire
l'appli de tourner à la ville
maintenant ils disent aussi des amis les
européens qui passe par et en touristes
qui le reconnaît
un cadeau très apprécié exactement leur
cherche des poux et l'indienne mangent
les poules sans mari j'ai pas pu faire
cette prise de vue parce que j'ai
l'occasion de le voir mais quand j'ai
voulu prendre la caméra l'alien avons
voulu recommencer
les indiens se noue n'ont qu'à seul
instrument
c'est une petite flûte qui fait un os
entre souvent en silence un bambou
qu'elle sonnerait c'est un centre et
monotone comme vous entendez d'ailleurs
très discordants est ce une salle maudit
des déserts qui n'ont dans le fond ni
queue ni tête parce que si jamais la
même chose
je suppose que ce n'est pas une mélodie
qu'il répète constamment qu'ils
connaissent par coeur il improvise pas
de chance connu
non non il a promis depuis c'est ça il
improvise les indiens ont beaucoup
d'animaux s'ils vivent parmi eux des
animaux qu'ils ont chassé qu'ils n'ont
pas tué ils n'ont que blessé lancement
les conserves en liberté avec le une
compagnie pour eux cette indienne
recherche des carottes de manioc
je vous avait permis à une précédente si
on justement faire le couac
ce sont des sortes de tubercule qui
poussa presqu'à ras du sol on lirait des
betteraves d'ailleurs et elle pousse
tout de suite en dehors du village près
l'écart mais je ne pense pas qu'il fasse
de cultures spéciales pour sa lancée
carottes son rap et ça produit une pub
qui sera décantée puisque quand il
assiste
c'est un poison mortel et ensuite séchés
au soleil
il formera le coin et le ralliement
national ce couac et manger plupart du
temps entre en fait dans un peu d'eau
est vraiment l impression quand les
entendre ils sont très propres
on les voit constamment les grandes
personnes dans la rivière et les bébés
sont lavés avec les ustensiles
d'ailleurs très européen
il apprécie le prussien plus ou moins
prévu d'envoyer ses ustensiles qui
montre bien le passage de la
civilisation que laurent que l'on voit
par terre cet enfant qui a un jouet ont
souligné coloré une once mignon notre
jour de flux quand des hommes se lasse
pas de souche d'un s'annonce nous avons
des qualités
le soir ont lieu les danses qu son usage
que jouant quand on est de passage au
centre aimons notre planète à une sorte
de piétinement sur place ils se parent
de maximum de colliers de perles qu'il
possède quelques plumes dans leurs
caches s'excuser devant et derrière pour
les hommes devant pour les femmes
seulement
il ya des zones qui dansent ils on n'est
plus au temps des plumes sans les plumes
genre de pain genre de perroquets de
haras exactement tout ça est très câlin
et très colorés
mais arras ans tués pour être mangés qu
ils ont envoyé ouest
pas sûr au mollet les sortes de graines
l'écho scrutin dans lequel la graine à
sécher qui fait un bruit de pénurie de
l'eau les indiens certains anja savonet
voix ressemble étrangement des femmes
oui ils ont un système pileux très peu
développé et mode et budget confondez
assez facilement d'ailleurs entre les
hommes et les centres f1 a parlé à des
plus âgés miens sont ils portent sur
leur poitrine les sortes de glace je
croise tous une sorte de légende honneur
pour eux bon tous ne l'ont pas tous
n'ont pas ces données aux guerriers en
principe le capitaine qui la possède
mais voyez là vous avez celui de droite
il manqua mais une glace qui l'a achetée
à saint-laurent-sur-manoire de
l'exposition c'est un avantage plus le
papillon qui est posée sans l'ombre
notre bannière c'est plutôt fatigant
pour lui après une journée de chasse
eh bien merci albert lot pour cette
intéressante série ce que vous allez
repartir bientôt j'espère maintenant
faire java sumatra où paraît-il entre
des papillons splendide qui valent des
prix très élevés
alors bonne chasse et ramenez nous
nombreuses images merci
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de gilles berlocq et le
seul enjeu péters montage pierre michel
rey sont paul bonnefond illustration
sonore denise glaser